okay so today we're very happy to have
joseph urban
who's going to be talking to us about
combining learning and deduction over
formal math corpora so please
so hi everybody
thanks for the introduction i'm
happy to
tell you something about what we do in
my group in
track
in particular a lot of this work has
been done in the recent let's say seven
years
uh funded by this eic project ai for a
reason that we have been running here
for about five six years now
so so this is the outline like i'll say
briefly something about motivation
uh mention computer understandable math
uh explain or make a sort of a summary
of how we combine
crm proving with various kinds of
machine learning
show you some demos and then depending
on the time
i may go into explaining like the high
level high-level low-level and mid-level
ways of combining
uh like some learning-based guidance
with uh deduction
and then again like if there is more
time i could say something more about
like neural based synthesis and
conjecturing
and autoformalization but
if i show you too many demos and i will
run out of time way way way before
before that
so so the very very
high level motivation
of what we do is automation of
mathematics and let's say the parts of
science that are related to mathematics
and the the sort of high level
uh
idea is that
both
mathematicians
and probably also scientists like like
hard scientists i
are doing
i
algorithms that combine learning and uh
pattern matching and
finding analogies
with some sort of deductive reasoning
some sort of deductive search
search for explanations search for
approves
and that
the mathematicians and the scientists
are
uh generally very good at sort of
combining these two two things and that
there are many interesting feedback
groups between like for example failing
to prove something and then learning
from the failure or learning from
related examples uh
inducing some high-level
terminology some sort of abstract uh
terminology when you do mathematics etc
etc
and
at least when we learn math we typically
absorb a lot of knowledge from various
textbooks and then when we when we do
math we are also able to use a lot of
knowledge that
uh we have studied uh so
the the sort of idea that
i started to work on some like 25 years
ago
is to basically get a lot of
mathematical
knowledge
in
a
form that the computer can understand
and
then sort of try to sort of start this
research
where we could do both
the deductive uh chains because
like
the knowledge would be sort of computer
verified so so so that's sort of
uh these large corpora of formal form of
mathematics that have been uh developed
let's say in the
several past decades but also because of
the size
we we could do some
interesting machine learning uh both
let's say statistical and symbolic uh
machine learning on these corpora
and and try to see how much we can
emulate for example some student who
who learns
from some textbook and eventually
becomes capable of solving
harder and other
exercises or
improving cardio and other theorems in
uh
in
all over these theories that he's
learning
so
the
sort of
one
one slight introduction to formal
mathematics is that it's it's this
program that probably many of you know
was developed like it goes back to
widenates and then russell
created the first
uh
formal foundations and
there were people like craig and albert
et cetera who who were
basically working on this program on
putting
embedding mathematics into into symbolic
logic into informal formal logic
and you probably also know that this
program has some sort of
side product uh resulted in due
touring's
proposal of the like universal computing
machine which ended up being actually
implemented
and then in the 1950s 60s people
actually started to think about
using
these these symbolic
logic machines into
doing doing mathematics
on them
and the the first like famous name in in
this
direction
is the brown who came up with a system
called automath in 1960s
and then there was a series of people
like robin milner doing galaxy a hundred
tribos and hindsight
where and we were doing mku7 and icl2 my
gordon doing hol
gerardia doing call clip awesome isabel
so so really these systems for doing
formal proofs
have been developed in the let's say
last 50 60 years
and what they do is conceptually pretty
simple like you write your axioms and
theorems in some sort of computer
understandable participle form
you state your inference rules
in a way that the computer understands
what is modus ponens for example
and then you you really write the
rules in such a way that the computer
can check check the proofs
so so it sounds simple but
it's not simple because there is like a
cognitive gap between
the humans trying to work in
the highest possible level and to omit
details and the details are boring
whereas the computer
and the simplest proof checker requiring
you to really do like millions or
billions of
uh of the lowest level mode exponentses
of the lowest level
uh inference types so so the research in
this field which is also called like
interactive theorem brewing has been
going on for for several decades now and
i would say it's still not mainstream
but there have been
uh several interesting large projects in
the last decade or two
which sort of brought it much more to to
mainstream and the developments are
really interesting
the the sort of ai
part of
let's say theorem doing
uh go goes back again quite some time so
so
there is for example the
the quarrel between the debate between
conquer
and hilbert where
juan carrera was
telling hilbert that if he puts
math in batsmath into like symbolic
logic and such theory
then
the mathematics will will become
that in some sense like it will
lose the sort of intuition
part
and then
an interesting person in in in this uh
sort of
debate this turing who who on one hand
proved undecidability
and uh on on the other hand he himself
is basically the founder of the field of
artificial intelligence so this is 1950
paper
where he proposes to
for example
use
learning machines to to learn
uh very abstract activities like playing
chess
and then
you you you have this
stream of
people like know pat langley who wrote
the bacon system
which in some sense invented the kepler
laws when
advised
we have done that
with the
uh am system and the european systems
which are introducing some conjectures
in mathematics in the case of am
and you have people
in europe like
the group in munich like
the argan singer stefan schulz etc
who
who basically started to
seriously think about what it would mean
to to learn
from previous proof experience from
previous
products created by automated theorem
viewers
uh so
so long ago
my my master thesis was about
trying to do symbolic learning this ilp
this inductive logic programming to
learn like explainable rules from
uh from
basically mathematical corporates from
systems like mizar and imps which are
to older systems for formalizing
mathematics
and let's say that since then since like
uh
we have been
developing
a number of approaches
for
both symbolic but more like statistical
methods
how to how to learn firm proofs in large
formal
mathematical libraries
and how to combine them with um
various like theorem proving
methods in like various feedback groups
etcetera etcetera
oh
what i
found
also
quite
interesting
is a talk
by
ben garzo like this
um talk he gave him track about three
three years ago
when he explains like the the various
shades
of ai
and in particular like he he sort of
makes nice distinctions between
what is ai
what is machine learning what what is
deep learning like many people today
believe that ai is just deep learning
but we probably all know that it's not
the case and
the deep learning methods can do some
things but
i fight back in some other things oh i
i should also say that
like
some
of this research is like these motivated
by this big ai visions like automating
verifying math law etc which goes back
to leibniz so
john mccarthy has a nice
essay about how the world could look if
he could
reasonably easily produce
truths about
some sort of common sense
uh ideas
and that the practical impact of
like some sort of ai based proof
automation
is today
in in boosting the productivity in
large
verification projections
uh
so so that's that's some sort of very
quick
uh motivation and now i'll
tell you
a bit about or give you
an overview of how
we today combine
machine learning with
uh the the various uh theorem proving
and deduction methods
so so the sort of oldest and
most uh easy
one
is is this sort of high level guidance
of how to make the theorem triggers
when you when somebody gave you
something like a mathematical textbook
written formally in a formal
language that is computer understandable
and your task is to
prove the next lemma or the next
conjecture
over
given all the knowledge in the textbook
and if you if you did that like 20 years
ago over
some some
big uh formal mathematical library which
would have like let's say 50 000 lemmas
in it and 10 000 definitions
then the automated theorem theories that
have been developed
at that time
until then
would have very low chance of proving
that
because
of the algorithms that they they're
using which sort of
uh in some sort of
brute force like reasonably smart but
still fairly brute force way
uh generate lemons from from the lemons
that are already there in the beginning
and
that
can be
very much improved
if you
have some way
how to pre-select
the dilemmas for improving your next
conjecture
so so that that that's a task which
in some sense is similar to some sort of
googling right like you you you get it
very
and now you are sort of googling your uh
set of
thousands of possible lemmas for for
those which are the most relevant ones
and those that sort of give you the
highest chance of proving your next
conjecture
without them being too many so that they
sort of
do not suffocate the automated theorem
period
in
[Music]
in how how it sort of
infers the
or
some sort of searches for
uh for the truth of that conjecture so
so that's what we at some point started
to call paris selection basically you
sort of select
premises from from your large textbook
to to prove the next conjecture
and you you can do well with
more or less simple machine learning
algorithms for that
and you can sort of combine them with
the deduction with some interesting
feedback groups
uh
the sort of
very
technically challenging task is is the
low level uh guidance of automated
theorem theories
so so
so automated theorem periods are
relatively fast and typically fairly
efficiently
low-level
implemented
tools
that in in the best implementations like
vampire improver etc
can do
i don't know like
maybe
or let's say thousands of inferences per
second so sometimes
like let's say maybe hundreds of
thousands inferences per second
so so now imagine you want to guide a
process like that you you at each point
you you have the
opportunity to choose from many possible
inferences
and
if you if you decide to guide it by some
smart machine learning method that you
have trained so
many
you know thousands millions or billions
previous proof situations
then if you have something like some
crazy big transformer
telling you
what should be your choice of the next
inference
uh then
you might sort of end up being extremely
slow compared to the original automated
hearing so if the transformer gives you
advice like
uh once per second or
i know
and
10 milliseconds then
if you if you do everything right then
then that's okay
but typically like you are
not proving the same thing all the time
so so if you just memorize them uh
that will not be helpful so so typically
there is some search component even with
the best machine learning methods
and if if you need to backtrack if you
need to do search
then
if you you cannot use extremely slow
like machine learning guidance for for
guiding the automatic theorem
so so this task like the low-level
guidance of automated theorem previous
is really
technically challenging and quite
interesting
in the sense that not not every
um
every like uh best uh machine learning
or the planning methods will work for
you here
and then
there is sort of a mid-level ground
when you have
in in some interactive theorem previous
uh you have
a way how to
program
bigger reasoning blocks for called
typically tactics
which
can be
composed to to sort of
pro progress the the true state
to advance the proof state
and typically you you only apply
uh
relatively few of them compared to the
low level inferences into which
they ultimately translate
uh so so let's say you might
apply something like 20 to
sometimes 10 sometimes 20 sometimes
maybe 50 tactics and there it makes a
lot of sense to to sort of
guide
those bigger blocks by by the machine
learning so so
that has been quite successful in the in
the recent year that people
people who do this sort of mid-level uh
guidance of the interactive crm
improving systems
then there are
like tasks like for example sierra
exploration
when you
let's say get some initials
etc
and then you you you may
uh
also get some ultimate conjecture you
want to prove
uh but
you you know that the ultimate
conjecture is quite far and that you
first need to develop the theory so so
theory exploration is
basically
uh trying to
find interesting conjectures trying to
prove them or disprove them
learn from the process and in some sort
of guided
or
slightly guided way build up the theory
so so that you can prove your ultimate
conjecture or a set of conductors etc
and like there are all these feedback
loops that i already mentioned like
between the learning and the reasoning
that are happening very often in what we
do
and the last bullet point is this auto
formalization which is like
also
today
uh a task that seems to be quite
approachable given like the latest
advances for example in machine
translation
where
you would
want to have a system that takes
later written paper or
something
less formal
and tries to sort of refine it into
fully formal
statements in one of these like formal
uh
formal math
systems and
ultimately prove it so so you would also
try to refine
the high level proof it and informally
by the mathematician into something that
kind of really future
so so this is like the
overview of
at least
most of the methods i would say
there
there are a bunch of datasets that are
being created like since like basically
uh initially like i i did a large data
set film from the mizar library like
this mml stands for mathematical library
uh so that's been going on for almost 20
years now
and there's a bunch of benchmarks based
on that like this mpdp challenge etc
uh larry paulsen and his collaborators
like jasmine blanchett
uh have been
doing
uh similar work for isabelle and the
afpd archives of former proofs again
like since something like 2004 2005.
a large dataset has been created by the
flyspec project which is the
formal verification of the kepler
conjecture by tom hills
so that that's been going on like like
the
ai
slash theorem through inquiry since like
etc etc so so there is uh quite a lot of
data today if people are interested in
in in doing this research
and
like especially for this sort of auto
formalization task
people are more and more looking at like
the this informal or let's say some
semi-formal
uh mathematical datasets like for
example proof wiki which is
uh informal but the proofs there are
written
following
some sort of unified format or stacks is
a similar uh mathematical purpose for
that
and then there is obviously archive
which contains like everything right so
that's not as controlled as the other
ones
oh demos uh so
i i don't know how how many of them i
should do
uh
maybe i'll show you
at least a couple of these this first
one for example and now i think some
weird things will happen i need to
switch to
this
and go to here
and hope for the best
uh-huh yeah so this sort of works let me
try to choose the phone size
and
click here
i'm going to use the font size again
so so
this is just to show you what i'm sort
of talking about so
this is uh
one of the older formal math system
called visa and a formalization of a
reasonably general statement of the
pythagorean theorem in the
so you say that you have some real
unitary space some sort of hilbert space
basically
and you have two points in it which
would be like vectors i guess which are
orthogonal
and then you state the the
equality so if you do x plus y
and it's norm squared then it equals x
naught squared plus y norm squared so
that's what you expect
and then you can see some natural
deduction proof after
uh the statement
which says like what x be some arbitrary
but fixed real unitary space let x y be
some points of x again you sort of fix
them for the
sake of the proof you assume that they
are orthogonal
and then you start deriving some lemmas
so so you say that
by the definition of orthogonality
we can derive the x scalar product y
equals
zero
and then you continue like by
the definition of um
what it means to be a real unitary space
like what it means to have a scalar
product in the united space you know
that if you take a vector in this case x
plus y
and you scale it to like this itself
it's greater or equals here etc etc so
so you sort of do
these
steps always referring to
uh to the database of definitions and
theorems that you already have
formalized
and ultimately you you sort of derive
the
uh the equality that you want to do so
so this is
uh
you you would say pretty standard proof
uh like
i would say about 20 lines for
uh for the
written by the human formalizer in this
case
so
for about two years we have been now
running
a
large
reinforcement leveling group
where we take
one of the best automated theorem
previews called e-program
and
let me maybe show you show you the slide
related to it
but i'm showing the demo
uh-huh so this will be the slide
um so so so there is about 60 000
problems in this library
and
the
the improver
by itself without any
learning uh from its previous successes
like by just running the heuristics
which were pre-programmed into it
can can prove about 15 000 of these like
let's say 60 000 programs automatically
in 10 seconds
and we
we take these 15 000 troops and we train
some sort of machine learner that sort
of guides the inferences
and we we plug this uh machine learner
into improver
and then we run it through only 60 000
problems again
and we do it in two different ways like
one is that we only run it with the
machine learning and the other one
that's this first one and the other one
is that we combine
the
advice given by the machine learner with
the internal heuristics that are
pre-programmed in the program so the
second method typically works better
and in the in the first round after the
first training
it improves the performance to 20 000
from 15 000
and then then we repeat this process
about six times
and
like in in the sixth iteration the the
best method
uh
again when
in 10 seconds of real time
uh achieves like 25 000 proofs and
solves about 25 000 problems
and improves the original performance by
about 70 percent
so so that's the
start
of this
uh experiment that i'm sort of
describing here and that we have been
running for
like two two more years
and and this uh the statistics here
oops i jumped to something
i didn't want to jump to
oops
ah
here we are so
uh so so the statistics here
shows you
what the e program was doing like how
how the proof uh was done
so so this says that the e-proverb
initially got
axioms like formulas
so so these are either pre-selected
uh by the user or they can be sort of
guessed by some sort of google search
on top of the whole mesa library
uh
those 332 got translated to 440 clauses
so so that's the sort of standard
classification that um
is typically done by the
state-of-the-art automated theorem
periods
and then
uh the theorem preview that like 4000
nontrivial loops of its um
algorithm that's called given closed
loop in in case of ethereum
and in these four first thousand
iterations
it derived about 65 000
new facts new new ones
so so the
choice point
is like
in each of these loops of these given
clause loops
you need to choose
one of the like initially 300 or let's
say 440 clauses that
quickly grow to be 65 000 goals poses
and and decide
which one will be the next one
with which you will
you will do the inference with the
previously uh chosen clauses so so
that's obviously like a extremely
important choice point
because like here you can see that
ultimately that the proof produced by
ethereum like fully automatically has
only 181 steps
so so in principle
uh if you chose the right 181
[Music]
steps
then then you could do the proof in
like
just that number of inferences not not
in
4000 inferences so so
that that also shows how quickly the the
search space goes here like in at the
end of the
uh of the search space which here took
like 20 28 seconds
you have 65 000
um choices like you you you can choose
from 65 000 pauses
this with which you can do the next uh
inference round so so so that's where
sort of the machine learning uh really
helps to sort of guide this uh explosive
process
uh so so that's uh
one
reasonably quick uh example
i
may try to show you
another one
uh
yeah so so this one took us seriously
longer like it took
almost uh four minutes and it's
also
much longer and the the tricks uh like
like the various machine learning uh
tools
or combination of them
were uh more involved here
uh so um
again i can show you the the proof
written written by the human
so so it says something like you you
have a subset of
the real numbers
and uh
you
you are assuming that the subset
are the rational numbers between some
real numbers a and b
and then you claim that the closure like
the normal topological closure of a
equals the the close interval a b
and
like the mesa proof at this point is
quite involved so i think it's about 80
80 lines in in nizar so that's sort of
starts to be
quite time consuming to formalize such
such things
and
like again you can look at the
statistics here so so you
start from 100 pre-selected axioms most
likely be selected by by some sort of
this sort of premise selection
uh it took about 5000 of these inference
loops
generated about 440 000
uh
what
what is uh sort of interesting here is
that we
we have this three-phase enigma which is
the
it stands for
[Music]
like intelligent guiding machine
efficient uh efficient uh inference
guiding machine
uh so
instead of just doing
like
one predictor we use actually three
predictors here which are
differently
efficient differently fast
and differently precise
so
uh
the the sort of
fastest one we we call parental guidance
because we we call it immediately after
a clause is being
born or proposed to be born and we
basically evaluate a very fast
uh decision here like
an ensemble of decision trees on the two
parents of the clause that is about to
be born
and if if the parents
are not sort of evaluated as being good
good parents
prospective parents then we tell
everywhere don't even try to do this
inference so so that happens quite often
so so here we
use this like fast heuristic to reject
about one one-third of the clauses
immediately
what we also do and that that's
interesting because that's that's like a
complete logical method
it's called aggressive subsumption
and subsumption in first of the theorem
period means that we
[Music]
never
uh create a clause
for
which we already have a stronger version
so so for example if you
have p of x where x is universally
quantified you will never generate v of
a by
it's like doing this for the all the
generated causes is quite expensive
because you need to have pretty good
indexing to sort of quickly look up
which goals could be subsuming which
other clause and subsumption is actually
np complete like which is one to one
clause assumptions and p copy
but like
what is quite interesting is that uh
like the aggressive subsumption
roughly uh prunes about the same number
of causes as the
like very quick machine learning
guidance like this parental guidance
and also
the two methods are roughly of the of
the same speed at this point
and
so so this side the first let's say two
phases
uh on top of that we we run some
relatively fast gradient boost trees
which again we select
from these let's say
remaining
200 000 closes
the ones that still look good and the
last stage
is the most expensive which is like some
sort of deep learnings on graph neural
network
where we put all the clauses that have
been considered good already
into a graph
with the sort of new
uh but good looking clauses and we look
at them as a graph of let's say 1 000 or
2 000 clauses together
and the graph neural network has been
trained to sort of uh do do several
rounds of message passing the team
between the clauses in in the graph
and ultimately select the the ones that
or rank
them according to how
good they they look for uh for the
uh serial improvement so so so we really
needed all of this to to get this proof
like we couldn't
do this before
oh so that's
let's say
another
example
uh
i will
not go into sorry
and do
many
[Music]
more like one uh
one thing
i could probably show you
is
a formally apps
uh formalization
uh
formalization
demo
uh let's see how long it will take us
so so this is
uh an autoformalization demo where we
took the whole white uh fly spec uh
corpus
which is fully formal but we
informalized it so so we basically
made it uh produce
like these
statements formulas
that are ambiguous like minus minus
minus minus x equals x
and now now you you are not really sure
what what it is
like what does the minus uh mean
and uh
we
in in this case
the
this is no deep learning this is uh
probabilistic context free grammars that
are trained on the corpus of
fully disambiguated versus
the
ambiguous
formulas
and
uh
the
the trend uh
pcfg parser
gives us like uh the the most likely
parses with respect to the to the corpus
and then
we we have this hammer that the sort of
relatively strong
automated reasoning uh tools on trains
on on the on the fly spec purpose
that we run to to confirm or try to
disprove
the
uh the conjectures that
sort of produce the disambiguations
that are produced by uh by the
probabilistic person
so so that's like a slightly uh
different thing that sort of depends on
having a relatively strong automated
oh
i'll i can show some more the most like
there if we have time left
uh
i'll say a bit about like this high
level low level and mid level
uh ways how how
to automate the theorem queries
so so this premise selection is as i
already said you you have
many many effects to choose from
and you you sort of want to choose the
right ones that give you a high chance
of automating their improving
and
the the sort of
way how to do it the strongest ways how
to do it today are in machine learning
the
the the systems that
do this that sort of
uh choose from the large itp library
uh
the like reasonable number of facts
translate the itp formalism into some
easier atp formalism referral logic
and then try to prove there and possibly
reconstruct the group back in the pluto
systems
are called hammers after larry paulson's
sledgehammer
so
about five six years ago the systems
could do 40 to 45 percent
and this has been done like for
basically all the main systems like
isabelle missouri the whole
uh whole light 5 spec gold 4 and even
coke
uh last year
thanks to
training the internal machine learning
guidance which i just showed you
we got it to 60
on on desire so i i guess
uh
we will now have a series of papers
where we will
show that also on the other corpora
uh the the let's say 40 45 percent can
be
[Music]
raised to
to these higher numbers when you
do this sort of low-level guidance and
be able to make it here improvements
the the system
like for premise selection
uh we have tried a lot of stuff so you
can
train them by looking at some sort of
syntax features like what are the
symbols in the formulas or some walks
in the pastries
you can also
look for like more semantic features
like for example the validity
in finite models is a
interesting feature
of a formula which you will typically
not get by some deep learning because
the big planning methods are not
uh as combinatorial as when you run some
finite model finder
uh
a lot of
stuff came recently like this
convolutional
uh recurrent neural networks graphical
networks
uh but but also like gradient booster
decision trees etc so so
this is
this is like a open
open field for improving uh and trying
your
favorite uh machine learning method and
obviously ensembles are also
pretty useful
i'll just give this slide
and then the
you you you can search around these
feedback groups there so the oldest one
is this machine either for automated
reasoning but i did in 2006
where you basically
have a set of problems let's imagine
like you have like 10 000 problems
and then you prove some problems you
learn the premise selection from them
and then thanks to that you saw some
more problems and then again you and the
penis section on top of that etc
so so that really
uh like here you see some some recent
curves from this when we experimented
with various
machine learners in this i think
like the canon scania sniper xd use
xgbes as you use the gradient booster
decision treats
parameters differently and you can see
how many rounds of this proving and
learning could be run and how how much
problems they can prove and this is
interesting like even though
the set of problems to eventually
plateaus
the the set of different proofs which
means like the set of different
premise sets
from which we can uh prove something
still grows sort of linearly here here
and this is some histograms for that
uh the low-level statistics
so the sort of canonical and
easily most easily explainable low-level
system that we did so the first
is this connection tableau the link
system that we lean connection tableau
where you
have you start with a set of first order
clauses and you can do the extension and
the reaction steps on them
and the proof finishes when all branches
are closed which means that you have
electro and its
contradiction in its negation on the
brain so on the right hand side here i'm
showing a closed connection tableau
that you can construct from from this
initial
set of clauses
and uh the advantage of this is that you
the the partially constructed tableau
is is reasonably compact and can be used
as some sort of true state description
for for the machine learning tools so so
that's what we do like at each point
when the tableau is partially
constructed we ask it like which of
these clauses should we use for foreign
extension steps so you have some set of
actions which are the clauses and the
two states to which the actions are
applied so so that can be
like easily used for some machine
learning reinforcement learning uh
setting
and we we did a bunch of iterations
starting with this machine learning
connection preview and then doing a
female code because the mail code was
too mildish
and we ended up with um an rl code which
is reinforcement planning connection
preview
where we did basically the alpha zero
algorithm the monte carlo research
and
that sort of
does some uh three three based
uh search use using this uh heuristic uh
called uce which somehow balances
the exploration of new actions versus
the exploitation
of the good uh good actions
uh and
the this sort of is guided by
learning
policy which is which actions or clauses
you should select
and and the value which is telling you
how good is the currently produced
partial tableau
and you you sort of repeat this like you
you again pluck the strength policy and
slide you into
into the proverb and you prove something
and you learn from it and proof again
etc so so these are the monte carlo
trees uh produced by that
and and here you can see like how
it behaves so ultimately after five
proven learning iterations
we improve over the original bingo
which can prove
1143 testing problems
by a 42
person
because we can we can do 1624
of the programs and here you can see how
the sort of learning iterations sort of
race um the performance so so that's
that's the simplest level uh setting
and and this sort of reinforcement
planning has been repeated since then in
many other settings like like the
episoding that i was
um
uh talking about and like
uh
it has been improved also in this uh
lean connections up in
oh
so this is the this is the enigma this
is the state of the art uh saturation
theorem progress
the
today we have this multi-face
architecture which sort of balances the
expansive deep learning with the fast um
faster methods that do a lot of useful
pre-pruning
uh this is the slide that i was already
showing that sort of shows you how far
you can get
and like one i just think about the
methods that we are using like the deep
learning methods
is that
they unlike for example transformers
which are
remembering the names that you are using
the graph neural network that we use is
totally
symbol agnostic it doesn't understand
the symbol so it only looks at the
term graphs or the clause graphs
and it only knows that the symbol here
is the same as symbol as the symbol day
but it doesn't know that it's plus or
multiplication
so so we we think and we actually
measured that
that it generalizes much better than
transformers so for example the the
graphene network trend on on this old
mizar library which we did most of the
visa experiments
generalizes very nicely to something
like 13 000 theorems in a new version of
the visa library
which contain like 50 more than 50 of
them contain
new symbols new concepts
uh which would like totally kill a
transformer because that's not how the
transformer is trained but the graphical
metric like really has basically the
same performance on on the
on this new library as on the
old
library
so
that's
uh i think i'm running out of time
uh so so that's uh at least
this sort of high level and low level
guidance
and then there is this mid-level
guidance which is sort of something in
between so so i will skip over it
but then there are all these interesting
like conjecturing and uh neural
rewriting tasks which i may
show you
maybe during
the question time uh for them also so so
that i would say what we
what we today
are quite focused on
is
synthesis of interesting
objects like witnesses like for example
existential witnesses in the proofs or
algorithms in the tools so so recently
thibault yeah who has done a lot of
interesting stuff
has created a system which
does
like invention of algorithms for oei
centered sequences
so if you give it the primes
it will try to generate an algorithm
that
understands
understands primes
and
typically like in this case it finds
very much pseudo crimes
uh so so you you could actually show if
you if you modify this up to 170
that
you get you get that crime somewhere
somewhere down there oh it really takes
a while to remove it oh
oh so
i i would say
um
yeah sorry take some
um oh it's here yeah so you can see that
341 which is not the prime is uh is
generated by by this program purpose for
for this uh sequence so uh
uh so so that's definitely one of our
current focuses like to
generate
um
to learn how to synthesize
uh algorithms how to synthesize
um uh important existential witnesses
how to synthesize conjectures
uh
so
let me show you like sometimes like two
years ago we even trained like gpd to
try to synthesize full proofs and that
was quite fun because
some of the things gpd can do and some
of the things like it totally doesn't
understand so so here
it's sort of
reasonably proposes the proof structure
but it at some point it needs to do some
non-trivial step and it totally misses
the points of like what it should be
doing like
it it generates a syntactically correct
lemma which doesn't really produce which
is incorrect and doesn't really produce
anything useful for
uh for the proof
but but sometimes like just just running
gpt can can do like reasonably
interesting things like for example
generalizing
uh a lemma in the library
uh from finite groups to arbitrary
groups
which is actually correct so so you can
you can or
like doing funny conductors like this so
we want to prove that sequence is
increasing on some interval
and it conjectures that every
differentiable function is increasing so
so
but we recently we have already found
this yes
try to wrap up in the next few minutes
please if you can yeah yeah so i'm i'm
almost there so i have already show
shown you the sort of autoformalization
demo
which was not based on deep learning
so so
uh this is an experiment that we tried
like four years ago to to do recurrent
neural networks with attention for
autoformalization
and
we train on
pairs of
latex
like tokenized like this
and and media which is a formal language
and
like here you can see this is the last
slide
how how the training proceeds uh and
what it produces
so
uh this is the correct mizar version
and and these are the outputs of the
trained uh system after let's say
thousand two thousand three thousand
training iterations
and you can see that initially like it's
total
garbage basically
and but quite quickly the out of the the
recurrent geometric
year
gets to produce
a formal
miser statement that is actually
in this case
alpha equivalent to to the correct one
based based on this like that
so so so that's
what
people
are trying to do more and more to
basically train such systems that would
turn your latex into your uh formal
mathematical statement
uh
there are some challenges and that's
of which some we have already
sort of completed
lots of acknowledgements references
and we have a nice conference
called aitp artificial intelligence and
theorem brewing
which is happening this year
in september
in
france so if you're interested like you
can probably watch it online this year
so that's it um thanks for your
attention and i'm happy to answer in any
questions
thank you so much thank the speaker it's
great um
and yeah we're
we're a bit into what should be the q
and a session but that's okay we can we
can take a few minutes to do some some
questions so
um
anyone wants to
raise their hand to ask a question uh i
think i see valeria do you want to ask a
question
yeah um thanks joseph that that was
really very good i i kind of got to
understand a bit more how different
players coming to this but my question
is is about is from
a logic point of view so you know
there's enough i mean there's too many
different tier improving systems and
they don't talk to each other very well
as we know
and and so the question i have and and
there's some kind of debates going on
right there's the debate between
and and lean or kind of being classical
logic and intuitionistic logic as a
basis and so i wondered if you have your
own view on on
and now you kind of showed the the i
mean the link up thing which kind of
it's
it it's good because it can do some of
the
non-classical logics or at least it's
good for me for doing linear logic and
stuff like that
and so i wonder if if if out of this
whole
and you know from most of the stuff that
you were talking about seems to be
agnostic on what the logic is so i
wondered you know
what is your conclusion along those
lines i mean
yeah that's the question
oh yeah i i guess you already
got it like i'm pretty agnostic as long
as you have uh some search of some sort
of deductive search
in in some reasonable logic i i think
these combinations of learning
with the directive search are pretty
agnostic they they they will
very pretty generally
uh
so so that's one part of the answer i
guess the
the other part you are asking
is like if i have personally some
preference for uh
for
uh for for these logics and and systems
like
um
and i would say i've been
[Music]
like initially i just studied
mathematics and i when i saw the miser
system being done in the setting that
was taught to me as a mathematician like
from basically first of all the logic
concept theory it was whatever i could
understand and
the fact that they could do things and
and that something was good for me
because i i could basically translate it
for for this automatic theorem previous
but but then i worked for six years in
the netherlands with the coke people and
like you know i i understand their point
of view i like constructive mathematics
inclusionistic mathematics has a lot of
interesting
properties right like you have this
as programs like you you you have all
these ideas about program extraction
from from pools
uh
and and obviously there are like these
deep philosophical
things about
why you should be doing intuitionistic
use
but then again like you you you get
systems like cleaner which were
originally
uh even
having two branches like we had the
homotopic theory branch and the
classical branch
and then
this somehow
um evolved like like you have people
like kevin buzzard who says that he
doesn't care about intuition
then you have systems like isabel which
even doesn't go into the full
power of set theory like the set theory
there is limited but then again they say
that they
were in some sort of sweet spot of
of where you get most automation
so so the the spectrum is really really
light
and i
um i i like because i quite semantically
understand
the the theoretic setting
i i quite like it and i think that you
can do even when you are doing a lot of
other stuff like let's say multiple
theory
you know your guiding intuition your
guiding models are very often grounded
in such theory so so you can do like
these things like for example mahatma
ganesha
was doing in in his phd thesis
like you can say that
ultimately you may be in some set theory
but you have some sort of
layers of abstractions like like some
sort of little theories et cetera
where
let's say ultimately everything is
grounded in in some set theory
but you
you may not even have to say like what
is your particular construction of real
numbers like so so um
my preference is for something like for
example mohan was doing and i would say
the media people and the little theories
people are also doing it
and i'm
not
not not particularly
seeing
um like i have seen also some
disadvantages of working for example
independent type theory
uh so
yeah so so
my preference is more in some sort of
soft types and
like simpler systems than going into
some
more involved like let's say dependent
type theory systems but that's just my
preference and
doing all these things
is pretty much independent of my
preference
thank you that that's very i mean it's
very good to hear kind of
different
voices on on the debates and stuff i
have another question evan but you know
i'll let other people go first if they
have
if there are other questions um david
did i see a hand up from someone at the
office
uh yeah actually i had a quick question
um uh how long do you think it'll be
before um
some of a working mathematician will
actually want to use some kind of
automated uh
assistance from some from one of these
things
uh
so
some mathematicians will never use them
but um
i would say
it's really
becoming
promising in the sense
that after people like george gonzier
and tom hills that these breakthrough
projects like uh fly spec and
uh the other theorem
uh
there
there is now quite a strong um
community around the lean system like
what you could say that it's led by
kevin buzzard but you have
very very strong formalizers like mario
carneiro
helping with the with the whole process
and advising the mathematicians
and
i i would say
uh
the fact that these are really like
research level mathematicians who are
further advertising in their community
is
is pretty promising
and
um
it's
it's hard to say like
well depends on how you exactly frame
your questions like if the question
could be like for example when
will more than 50 percent of like
research
new research result may be formalized in
some system and that that thing
like if i if i was supposed to give you
some number i would say that it's
probably at least 20 years away from now
but but i i think
it's it's sort of coming like people
very quite uncertain for quite long time
but but but i think
it's it's it's becoming more and more
certain that such a moment will come and
it will not be
too too far from them
very interesting thanks
uh james m i think you've had your hand
up for a while you want to ask
yeah i was curious that you were talking
about uh as you expanded you were
getting more and more proofs that you
could do i was curious about the proofs
that you could already do did it learn
alternate uh methods of proving them
yeah yeah
so so that that happens really very
often
uh like one uh
one one simple
uh sort of demonstration of that
uh let me try to find it here
is
oh this graph
so so here
at the end so so so this is just the
premise selection when we have this data
set of 2000 programs and
the
proof then we learn
the the premise premises from which you
could more easily prove
the theorems
and and then you try to prove again so
so this shows you
that for
um
for for some of these
you you really get like 56
different proofs and and here by
different i only mean
that you prove them from different
premises from different assumptions
uh so
because
the the formal libraries are sort of
derivation graphs like large derivation
graphs
the
the more
and the smarter you are
the more you can expand the derivation
graph so so for example initially you
might be able
only able to prove your lemma
from its immediate parents in the
derivation graph
but if you
sort of learn better and especially if
you also do the low level learning then
you will be able to expand to the
parents of the parents etc etc and and
you will be able to to do longer and
longer throughs so definitely this
happens a lot and it also brings a lot
of interesting issues because we we do
not really know yet well
how to learn when we have multiple twos
of the same theorem like how how should
we
whether we should
choose only one proof and somehow make
the proving style across the whole
library maximally consistent so that it
sort of doesn't
confuse the machine learners or whether
we should just learn from all proves
that we have uh et cetera et cetera so
these are very interesting issues
thank you very much did were you able to
mind at anything that was
really surprising that a human wouldn't
have proved uh something basic this way
oh yeah yeah
that also happens quite quite often so
we
for example
in in this
uh
link um
like
it goes back like 20 years to my
master's thesis when we found
alternative proof but
here uh
the the misa theorem which is
uh something that somebody called a
carmichael's
theorem
on prime divisors
so so
you have two primes and m divides fib n
which is the end fibonacci number
and then you say that it means that um
m
doesn't divide uh fibonacci
r where r is smaller
than n so so so the proof in written by
the human is pretty long
and we couldn't
get it from
in the way in which the human wrote that
we couldn't get it by the automated
theorem period
so it was 122 lines
but we we found much simple proof
from different
premises
uh
because
we just found a lemma
which says that fibonacci m gcd
fibonacci n equals fibonacci mgcdm
and
once you have this lemma you you can
prove it
much faster you you don't need induction
like everything go goes goes very fast
so so this is really a very interesting
effect that we have been
getting for like the last 10 15 years
with these systems
because the automated theorem previous
are quite brute force and are not very
good at getting very long groups they
strongly prefer short groups
each time you that there is a opening
like this each time
there is a lemma in the library which
allows you to do a shorter proof than
the one which the human wrote
you you will almost always get that sort
of new proof new simpletive invented by
by the
aitp systems so yes this happens quite
often so i'm going to go ahead and stop
the live stream now um so let's let's uh
let's thank the speaker again so thanks
for
um
and
there are a few questions left so if you
have time you assist